[Music]
three two one action
welcome back to Oh Frank where we talk
about today we have Tess what's up we're
gonna talk about whatever we want I
didn't say with everyone if I didn't
know how did you caught on how's that
man how did you know you've been on the
show for a while like I should forgot
okay I I didn't pay attention the first
time well that we do this so that people
kind of know get a feel of you before
all your head start coming out did we
tell off the record with you yeah we did
yeah you know we spoke about like jungle
book and oh yeah and why in a parable
doctor and my parents are both doctors
and I knew the for the first sibling to
not go in the medical field no my my
brother is not in the medical field I'm
not the middle school and neither is my
sister oh [ __ ] that [ __ ] - like first
generation of cousins most of them are
are not doctor yeah that's austere
tastes like their parents generation you
know like it all gave up at the same
time you know anything is growing up we
never had to worry about anything
medical ever and that was one thing I
took for granted
yeah cuz row in Mahopac New York okay so
it's a it's an it's basically it's
Westchester New York Putnam County for
everyone from Putnam County out there
watch up nicely three guys yeah it's
like people my parents that's - I spoke
to him on the phone earlier but yeah I
did call them who's an interesting
conversation you're gonna be so yes
they're really [ __ ] dope dude awesome
I love them I couldn't believe how we
came at them out of nowhere and they
were down yeah I was pretty aggressive
you guys will see I'm just teasing it
I was pretty aggressive I'll be fine
your most watched video hopefully so a
lot of your family hours are an
entertainment
ah my brother is a my younger sister is
yeah how about like your cousins and
stuff yeah I have a couple of a couple
cousins and stuff like that dude what
what do you want to do man what's your
go-ahead mother she's an actor okay no
uh yeah well you are acting I am it up
you're in acting yeah yeah I like to act
saying dance studio you sing - I do sing
[ __ ] yeah did a rush and I saw you
yeah Russian uh that was the last thing
yeah that I did made you it's on Netflix
guys gonna watch it I just as these are
all the plugs
very cool run run through all my plugs
when you're in an LA party and
everyone's always gonna brag about the
last couple things oh my god to be feel
like they're cooked they can have a
conversation with somebody else I
usually I usually just say I'm an actor
and then if they ask me yeah because I
feel like I'm in a weird position where
certain people recognize me then certain
people don't recognize me and that's
totally cool but I always feel a little
timid to say what I've done do you play
the Hollywood actor [ __ ] where you just
got a [ __ ] braggadocio bout
everything your rattle yeah so I was
just hanging out with my buddy uh [ __ ]
it leo
Nardo you might know him I was hanging
out with Nardo any my buddy will if you
probably have seen you know that will
know about will yeah Willie Willie good
old will oh you know smithy will you all
yeah Will Smith yeah you know Nicki if
my wife Nikki was a douchebag she could
easily do that because she used to serve
him she was a waitress and she would
serve Leonardo DiCaprio all the time
what restaurant
I was really bougie one but he would
always get right a double vodka a double
Grey Goose in lime and soda and he would
just say keep him coming and he would
just drink like seventeen of them damn
his waffle Wall Street camera yeah no I
usually don't cuz I feel like that's a
turn-off yeah but a lot of people play
that game though they do it's new
artists parties it's part of yeah if the
Hollywood talk there's a give-and-take
there's a give-and-take you always got
to read the room I do I do hate the
conversation like so what you been up to
yeah that's brag to me Brett why does
they want to know he wanted up they
could plug himself see my time talking
to you that's the thing yeah and here's
the here's the thing and because when
when two people I think respect each
other
I don't you can tell they enjoy hearing
about each other's projects and what are
you up to what are you doing what's in
the future oh that's great like Oh lemon
will let me know and so that's a
different flavor then well what do you
do it what have you been yeah it's like
well or I tell people I'm an actor and
they're like okay well what restaurant
you work in no ma I'm like listen dumb
[ __ ] oh you mean I was injured
14 Emmys what the [ __ ] you know I'm
working and you look and all of garden -
I will say my first job in LA was PF
Changs
to have this velvet cake that's really
good the dessert was velvet - red and
I'll give you those questions actors or
just non-industry billets of everybody
it's everyone LA parties bro really they
say which restaurant you work out oh
they'll be like Tom and Joe it's a calm
yeah like I'm an actor
restaurants are so flexible so sometimes
I'll just say something funny like yeah
I'm the VP of Red Lobster yeah actually
great I mean yeah I'm the VP of Red
Lobster yeah cuz they're not gonna you
know by the I know the president of Red
Lobster is like a light yes [ __ ]
lineup shoes I like to make people
regret that they ask me what I've been
doing because you won't shut up no
they'll be like what you've been doing
and I'm like uh stuff you know a night
and I give them a chance to escape right
I go I've been depressed so this is
what's been going on yeah and I just
keep going and going and going and I'm
like yo thanks dude that was amazing I
feel so much [ __ ] better now but be so
large right there's obviously so many
shows and movies that I don't get an
opportunity to see or I haven't seen yet
you say you don't know if someone's
working on something really great
because it goes both ways yeah yeah like
if they don't know me then I maybe I
don't know them and they could be doing
something dude amazing it's all these
you see people that I kind of know that
dead so what you been up to all haven't
been seen you in a long time
and I'm like alright get ready I'm a vet
you're like here we go Stage five my my
whole thing is I don't see value in who
I'm talking to the recognizability cuz I
don't know who the [ __ ] thinks he is but
holy [ __ ] do I respect Banksy
so it's one of those things where it's
like I don't know
I can't just look at you and go oh okay
I like I know that you're this person
you've done these things oh you know I I
do think it's it's but you can you can
understand and kind of decipher the
situation very quickly after just being
around these people for so long
yes you know you know immediately who's
full of [ __ ] you know immediately who's
when real things no one yeah there's
like an overcompensation field through
the new guys they're the big talkers
yeah you know you're like yeah your
bills online recycle and well there's a
lot of people who do this whole thing
with like I'm head of marketing head of
development head of la blah blah blah
and I'm always like you're the worst
like your bottom feeder that's how I
know because you're fronting me with
these titles I know that you're [ __ ]
nobody and you're insecure about it yeah
right CEO of Sony get out of my face Bob
Iger never heard of you but I feel like
that's in every industry obviously the
only industry I know is entertainment
yeah what I think there's there is a
special Hollywood talk though that just
doesn't exist
you don't mean like yeah sure like your
name you have to conveniently name drop
in the projects that you do and all that
and there's a lot of ego that exists and
and it's like so their fragile egos - oh
another thing it's not just being like
egotistical it's like you're an ego and
you're maybe extra carefully because you
don't know who you rub the wrong way and
then they don't want they they talk all
this [ __ ] oh no - six six years ago I
bought this le party I'm talking to this
guy in a wheelchair and he's like yeah
blah blah blah blah and I'm like
whatever dude and that guy was Stephen
Hawking who was that conversation it was
kind of dark in there so used to hanging
out with Asian people and you're like
are you Asian
you can't troll me man it sounded kind
of auto-tune II a little bit what the
hell is this shut up
you're not t-pain wannabe he's like I
set up a party for the travelers of the
future and I'm like yeah okay I know
exactly what you're talking about by the
way he tried to throw a party for time
travelers he threw a party for time
travelers and no one showed up he send
an invitation but it only happened in
the past so nobody could know about it
until after it happened except for
unless you're at that time and then you
could show up at the party
he said no one came nobody came so
therefore there's proof that no one is
they saw him in there like I don't hang
out with that nerd see if you've got a
really hot chick maybe it would have
someone with time travel into a [ __ ]
showers are horny if I got a invitation
from Stephen Hawkins and you're like yo
show up I'd go no I would hundred
percent go chill with some future [ __ ]
yeah be like okay we banned four lokos
so now we have five locals try ban them
yeah I remember could for deliveries was
baked when I was in high school there's
good was him again what would made him
so great crack cocaine like Monster
energy drinks meets like [ __ ] a tall
boy it was like apps what was abstinence
abstinence lead you absolutely dead it
was like drinking nitrous oxide yeah it
really I remember a hat I had there was
a kid every won't say his name but his
name was Alex one say his last name and
he had one and then he threw up like
immediately after drinking he down the
whole day down the whole thing I was
first period
yeah this first period out DUIs I love
all because the calculus AP calculus Oh
a B not BC for all the agents out there
what's BC it's like the next level yours
you're smarter wait wait AP and then BC
also they're both AP classes but they
have calculus a B and then they have
Calculus BC if I remember correct for
Christ I don't know maybe I can't
remember I was long there's IB so yeah
so I B's like the AP equipment
international was it back I gave you say
the word international Bachelor do you
know a little known fact about part is
that he knows a [ __ ] ton about like
protons neutrons electrons but he
doesn't say [ __ ] about half of the stuff
that he knows that so it's not well I'm
gonna talk about you need yeah can you
lie if I give you just like an atomic
number I use things I've memorized I
know like all the atomic weights and
like the number where you just in Dubai
oh I was about I was a bio major
okay no chemistry physics and all
biology you good at stupid trans like he
doesn't know a lot sure you're like the
smartest person walking around and
useless information hi you don't front
that's what that's what linked it to me
and I didn't have to take a single math
class in college I took a strong take
all of our men in high school yeah you
majored in astronomy I took one science
class in college and whose astronomy I
loved astronomy Wow
I had to take in my senior year cuz I
was like you need once you're just
looking through telescopes all day
no I didn't look to receive what do you
do we just learned about astronomy like
Scott do you know when are we gonna talk
about like being Aries and [ __ ] Way
galaxy that's so cool
have you been to the observatory yeah I
have not died I've been in LA for like
13 years I haven't been in the
observatory the Griffith every time I
try to go something happens it gets
[ __ ] it's cool yes without a cause
that's what they found it is really they
did a lot of [ __ ] there I had no idea
I never launched a rabbit movie back to
the future hmm
I just watched some [ __ ] crazy [ __ ]
about James Dean's death because I
always nothing he rolled down a hill off
a cliff and died no he was in a Porsche
yeah you played chicken or something no
he was just like driving and like he
just was turning in a guy big a
basically guy just [ __ ] t-bone oh the
cliff boy it was not tea but he actually
hit him head on and probably the the
headlight of his car went through James
Dean's head oh it's like that she was so
load was he drunk
no James D was just speeding like a
[ __ ] so this guy he was about to
turn left on a highway every way and
then he was like man I think I can make
this left actually but then he didn't
realize James Dean's going like 120
miles an hour and then he just [ __ ]
hit ah
so James Dean t-bone or it's a
conspiracy what do you think happened
got assassinated by the Mafia why I
don't know I just like to think that
mafia is assassinate all those famous
people oh you need to go JFK as well
that's why do you think that JFK was a
conspiracy what do you think I don't
know much about it but I just ya know I
don't think wouldn't know like what's
they come what do you know I mean kill
them you think I've got two shots off in
that amount
I don't know what that means I know he
sniped him right I don't know I don't
know is it possible I had very little
experiment that you been theory they got
the Mafia theory
mafia theory and they got the Lyndon
Johnson theory that the CIA team George
Bush and all these guys oh man they
killed him because why cuz he was like
the first Catholic president cuz he was
Irish he was a he was anti-war ton of
policies that just rub people the wrong
way
mm-hmm yeah that's familiar and he was
anti CIA famously said he wanted to
disband us yes man the CIA oh interests
the telus community the time was against
him and they were cold Lessing power
around like the roswell crash and all
that [ __ ] and area 51 and all nitrogen
by me Bernie Sanders was on Joe Rogan I
think he said that if he was elected
president he'll release the area 51 and
tell everyone if aliens are real yes
Britain I would say that I thought it
was kind of smart oh there's like he
just got all the stuff I vote for him
just for that you know why he's genius
Obama said it to them no but but but but
Obama didn't Obama like buspar the JFK
stuff yeah he did yeah but people
weren't trying to sign up to rush the
[ __ ] area 51 Bernie Sanders saw that
and goes millions is people billions and
billions oh here's the thing
aliens have to be real they have to the
universe is so large yeah everyone here
you know documentary have you seen a
[ __ ] about the bizarre documentary Bob
Lazar no Nestle don't know [ __ ] about a
magician talkin no I'm just said I think
they're real do you think you did we
agree he's a whistleblower you said they
don't think they're here right now in
that offended me cuz Bob Lazar
says he knows her here no you didn't say
aliens oh he said the crap crap that's
why you stole it but yeah acknowledges
the existence I'm gonna take this I'm
gonna register ology and then the
[ __ ] element whatever the [ __ ] it's
called I forgot the names of someone be
lots of blah blah number but Zeta
reticulan huh Zeta Reticuli the star
system I got you bro I love this you
know why cuz life is boring its we need
to figure out guys you imagine meeting
an alien yeah how'd you hook up with an
alien yeah yes
pitties well if it looks like a
caterpillar I'm not [ __ ] that well
what if it had holes lower folds if it
saw she gotta watch the boys man it's a
funny scene up beside there with this
character named Adeeb and he's like he's
kind of like Aquaman but he has like
gills okay can I can I tell you guys
tough exam I just watched first episode
I really like it what does that mean he
has gills though yeah I mean his name is
the deep so he's like he's like Aquaman
he could swim no no he is just a hero
with gills but there's a funny funny sex
scene with he gets [ __ ] in the girls
on tell me are you talking about the
voice no I'm talking about the show
called the boys the boys oh my bad boys
on Amazon hearing boy yeah Bart kept
saying have you seen the boys and using
the boys I'm like the voice the voice
that sounds like a [ __ ] talent show
boy my mom watches like yeah he's got
gills and I'm like don't tell me yet
Shelton has you know gills
not stretch me the [ __ ] out man aliens
dude my uncle bob lazar watch that [ __ ]
but don't watch this new one I mean you
know but you and me Corbin or whatever
that guy sucks the got the beard would
be the most interesting thing is if
aliens showed up is how religious people
would react to that I've said this right
and like what would happen would they be
like the collapse of religion earth or
they just tie it into the fold would be
like this belt is you think so yeah I'm
talking about if they look even remotely
humanoid then they'll be like oh cool we
were still creating God's image at
school they'll tie it in and they'll say
it's either the devil or it's somehow
something else like he'll tie it and
they'll always try to tie it into the
Antichrist yeah they're like it's that's
what's gonna be really really
interesting and depends on what religion
- cuz some might just be like yeah we've
been waiting for them dude Buddhists
would be like oh that's [ __ ] sick
[Laughter]
Buddhists are like the stoners of
religion yeah yeah this makes sense like
yeah I'm the only gonna be a problem for
real like in Hindu like culture like
there's something in the scripture that
says that there might be aliens I don't
think there's like a specific Oh there's
aliens but it's it's much more you know
just like about the universe in space
you never seen ancient aliens they have
so much we're not tied to humanoids I
mean like we got monkeys and elephants
you know there's the blue god ones a
monkey ones an elephant right 500 arms
yeah so for us if we're not attached to
the whole you need to look like a homo
sapien you know what's crazy is how
being crazy
Scientologists look but if aliens come
up if he owns come down to the moon
accurate and then you're like yeah you
deserve it did yeah you don't you can
tell you come to my house to jump on my
[ __ ] but what if they come down they
go hey Scientology's foolish [ __ ] we
just came down to tell you that would be
classy I would be tired
damn they'll be crazy I wanna you know
there's this one episode on ancient
aliens and then they have this whole
thing about it's called a vimana it's an
Indian scripture thing and then they
there's they're talking about how like a
lot of Hinduism has space [ __ ] like they
do alien [ __ ] but if you if you kind of
translate the symbolism because back
then they didn't have the technology so
they just use things that I can thing
that that affords yeah they understood
but they had flying machines and all
that [ __ ] and I'm like damn dude and it
is like what the oldest religion in the
world or some [ __ ] right yeah yeah damn
dude I'm like culturally you know we
don't wanna practice hey I even if you
practice what would do what's the main
thing you would have to change probably
my diet the beef their beef they are
they begin or
and do they believe in like
reincarnation - mm-hmm is that where
Buddhism got reincarnation from yeah
well Buddhism came from Hinduism yeah so
it was basically a Hindu prince who was
like I'm out of here peace was
Siddhartha yeah and then he saw just all
this kind of struggle and suffering he's
like is Buddhism pretty big in India not
really it's more like a China the
Chinese my Buddhist I'm from India yeah
it comes from Hinduism and so Chinese
people went over to India and that did
that well I think basic again got them
at the time man you didn't got walked
over and it spread there and kind of
with this he went viral yeah the
original influencer he would have got a
brand deal immediately with merch
[Music]